[Music]
Scot Butterworth's a GameSpot you can go
read his review he named it six out of
ten he played like sixty hours or
something total yeah they still had a
he's playing a lot more yesterday just
to check it out but he's on vacation a
well-earned vacation after pax and
reviewing that game for us but we at the
office all kind of have different
opinions on this game some of us are
really diehard mass spec fans some of us
are kind of coming to it fresh yeah
and we wanted to talk more about it but
also we kind of want to branch off the
games were just talking about kind of
suss out whether we think Mass Effect
Andromeda might be improved down the
road I just want to get initial
impressions here at the table first
Kelly you're like sort of early in the
game I'm federally still oh yeah but I
think my biggest problem is the writing
mm-hmm for a lot of the dialogue yes so
just to get that out of the way
stilted dial yeah we get more into it
but I mean it's like especially the
flirting stuff is like my 13 year old
fanfiction I get real bad yeah it's like
oh you know when you're like 13 you
think being awkward Fairey charming and
you're like I'll just try to be extra
awkward it's like no don't don't try to
do that she's no writers no and from
persona no see I know persona I can do
this you know drop know best girl Jake
you like Mass Effect a ton you're doing
well you're a pimp something quick
you're doing the status party in the
Citadel explain this to me so gentleman
are actually playing through the end of
Mass Effect 2 we've actually done that
wrong mass sector right now we're just
trying to kill as many of our companions
as we can it's rough like we just killed
I don't suppose we killed a certain
character and it kind of broke my heart
I regret doing this whole series the
Gareth well that was sad I was like my
that was like a quick death like he got
shot in the face with a rocket and it's
like okay are you talking about when
they force you to cut off Morton's head
with a saw well it is the character in
question but that doesn't happen in the
game I want to play I know because I
don't worry everyone
um but yeah so I'm a big Mass Effect fan
I do like Andromeda I think in drama
there is a lot wrong with this game I
think the writing is
defense because like when you play a
Bioware game that's what that's what you
expect like good writing good story good
characters and all of that kind of falls
flat which is a huge shame there are
some characters that are okay there's
some characters that are good and there
are some like dialogue sequences and
like certain aspects of the story that
are really cool but when it boils down
to it like I think Scott actually
mentioned it in his review that like a
lot of that game needed to be cut like
the good stuff is buried and I think
that's very true like I played I think I
meant like 30 hours and now and there's
probably about like four or five
missions where I've like really enjoyed
as opposed like Mass Effect 2 where
every mission was like had its own story
had its own arc and it had like a cool
location and this it's like alright so
I'm flipping switches on a planet and
that leads to something else
like I like I'm I've been playing a
Sudoku puzzle for like the past 45 me
explain that quick how that works well
map sodoku house it oh who were I've
been waiting 5 thanks to this game and
I'm doing Sudoku puzzles yeah no that's
like the hacking and these remnant
terminals you come across I think I
don't it's not a spoiler now you know
there's like an ancient civilization
that I'll say but like the hacking in
this game is a Sudoku puzzle yeah like
before the show Jake was trying to do
one he's like just swearing in a
superior dude I got that their heart
it's just what why am i doing kodoku
exactly there are some simple ones that
take you like I don't know like a couple
minutes it's like that's fine you know
that's a nice diversion but then there
are other ones that I'm at for like 20
30 40 minutes and it's like what this
just brought this game to a grinding
halt yeah I like my theory was that in
the Andromeda galaxy the remnants to
protect their technology thought this
like really clever puzzle would
recommend all the cuz I mean aliens are
from a galaxy where that's like sold at
gas stations in like this is Sudoku it's
like what it's like a word search is
there and they're like oh sweet I just
gained access to this I didn't spoil it
I think though because I did just like I
guess kind of [ __ ] on Mass Effect
Andromeda lot and like to be fair I am
enjoying this game I am a huge Mass
Effect fan so maybe it's some maybe it's
rose-tinted glasses because like
it is cool being back in this universe
it is cool seeing a lot of these
different races again seeing that
interaction between different species
and I think the worlds are really cool
like you get to one later called elegan
which is by far one of the coolest
settings in a Mass Effect game I would
say at least in terms of an open one and
there's like six or seven different
planets you can explore some are huge
some are smaller but doing that is
really cool and it makes me
I just wish everything supporting those
cool areas was also cool but if your
Mass Effect fan like I think you'll
enjoy it yeah so one thing that you know
when Scott's reviewing the game
he's just judging the game on its own
merits right it's a review but a lot of
people think that we're disliking
Andromeda because in comparison to Mass
Effect one two or three it's worse but I
am I love those games but I didn't come
into this from like a fan side I came
into this and I just objectively don't
like this game for a lot of reason why
Kelly mentioned there's stilted dialogue
I don't think there's much momentum to
the plot what you despite the fact that
the idea of us being the alien coming to
a new galaxy and not being visited is
really cool whereas you know Mass Effect
one two three was really cool premise in
that it's this galaxy that has already
come to grips with the fact that there's
a lien life and it's got a galactic
government there's like you know
different dealings are helping each
other out or at war or have their own
problems that like humans know about
this game is just it's all brand new and
it fell into so many not just like
sci-fi tropes but also videogame tropes
like I immediately felt like I was
thrust into combat for no reason
there wasn't anything interesting about
the arrival in the Andromeda galaxy
unless you went around and like maybe
one out of eight NPC's was had something
like actually interesting problem that
didn't exist in Mass Effect one two
three these people just left everything
they knew behind and I don't know they
seem fine immediately
I didn't character creator side note
don't do character creator if you don't
want your dad to look like a offspring
of Jeff Goldblum and William H Macy if
they kind of like had an affair on the
side yeah he looks I don't have footage
of it thank God if I did I would
grabbed my computer here makeup so much
it doesn't look good because they kind
of like take this amalgamation of I
think I could be wrong I think they take
what your twin looks like if you pick
Sarah Wright or Scott writer will be
your twin and they take what both those
look like and kind of combine it and
what happened to mine was just a
monstrosity mine looks a little bit like
Edward James Olmos oh nice so it's fine
I was like ah the Battlestar Galactica
feel yeah it's never a bad thing yeah I
but like I said the writing this game is
just between the dialogue I don't think
the the pacing is great because you're
getting distracted by all these cyclists
the side quests I have problems with you
said you did four or five missions which
are interesting to use that's you've got
four or five on me like I didn't really
enjoy any of them that I played uh yeah
I mean well how far are you though I did
they're still on yost correct before no
no I did the next I'm on the you're
editing like you'll I need any other two
I did those two I'm on the one after
that
Hodari I'm doing this stuff after Volgin
Hvar oh oh okay so I mean I don't think
I'm as far as you but I'm into the game
and like I said this kinda reminds me of
Dragon Age Inquisition and that I'm
doing so much that doesn't matter and
you know I'm not judging it based on how
it compares to horizon there Zelda but
those games like I was exploring because
there there were stuff the stuff you
were doing like contributed to your
character or there's it's so meaningful
within the world this stuff just feels
like it's a checklist uh I was reading
your review over at Kotaku today I think
and I think it's Patricia Hernandez was
saying it reminded her of a really full
email inbox and it overwhelmed her and
she didn't know like which one to pursue
first and which one to actually kind of
prioritize and I don't tell me that the
Nexus is you know like it's things
aren't going well I'm trying to spoil
anything and that I won't but you know
things aren't like going according to
plan that's been evident from the
trailers and everything and but they
don't convey that they tell you that but
you don't see much of it you have to go
seek it out right and that was always
the case like that was what's cool about
Mass Effect one two three and some parts
of n drama that's the character at least
that's fun we're good nice do it yes
maybe I just haven't seen a lot of
examples and like the example I think of
right now doesn't come
till later but I think it's a pretty
cool example of how they are we are
going yes but I mean I don't know I
don't think it capitalizes on the cool
premise that it has right away and I
don't think it feels more like this like
almost like third-person the story
they're telling seems very separate from
the gameplays my main problem and that
has been my case throughout but I gotten
you're farther in but maybe it'll get
better for me but at the same time if
I'm 12 hours in it's still not grabbing
me and I don't want to be keep playing
well from what I've seen and from what
I've heard talking to different people
it sounds like depending on what you get
distracted by and what you choose to do
you could be having these vastly better
or worse experience with it because a
lot of people I know have been playing
for a while I've been like oh yeah it
really opened up and like it started out
with like a rocky start and the combat
was great but everything else was a
little rough and then you know I met
this character and it was really cool
and I have this cool arc but if you
decide to do a bunch of other [ __ ]
you're going to miss all of that and
you're gonna have a really bad you know
you could have a bad 30 hours and I
think that's probably the main problem
is you I mean
Patricia's metaphor is really accurate
where it's like if you just follow the
wrong trail if you have this
overwhelming email inbox and you find
something that's really bad and you keep
doing that and you never get rewarded
you're going to get burnt out really
quickly and to go back to the like elda
comparison the reason it's different is
you get rewarded consistently you can
get very distracted that game is very
overwhelming but you are almost always
rewarded by what you do and I think
that's probably a big problem with
Andromeda I also I mean I just I really
can't shake the the dialogue is just
unfortunately very amateurish like
there's a there's a character who
basically gives you her life story and
she's just let you meet her and she's
like oh well I'm trans and like I was
and it's like that's I always appreciate
the effort but like that's just so like
your first creative writing effort and
that really is so disappointing when
that's why I would want to play a Mass
Effect name I just can't shake that even
though I really do enjoy the combat and
exploration is cool and I like the
universe and I love space like it's just
really hard for me to to get past
I want to chime in as someone who really
has not really cared about mass effect
at all so you would say not to compare
it to games like Zelda or whatever but
for me I think it is possible to make
comparisons they're not direct ones but
you know coming off of games like
horizon Zelda persona 5 near like those
games make excellent first impressions
the the four hours I played of Mass
Effect Andromeda did nothing to excite
me it only pushed me away from the game
and trying to play it felt like I was
forcing myself to do something I really
didn't want to do
I think first impressions are very
important in this game honestly really
fails at doing that so you know as
someone who doesn't have like an
understanding of what the series can do
and what has been great out in the past
like it's there's a huge barrier there
because if you don't have that those
hopes and wishes
what do you don't know what to look
forward to like the combat starts off
very basic and in my opinion boring
right the game throws a lot of systems
at you like okay here's how you upgrade
all your profile trait has become
different warrior here all the skills
doesn't explain any of it the UI is a
mess the animations look like crap like
I could just go on and on and I don't
want to hate for the sake of hating but
there's something to be said for a game
that can't make an argument for itself
immediately like I every game I just
mentioned you know other than this there
was something that made me multiple
things that made me want to keep playing
we're like I couldn't put the controller
down like that that's a huge problem
this game has and I think that's
probably a reason why people may be
struggling to to really get into it
because it takes so long to justify what
it's trying to do yeah I mean - it's not
an RPG but looking another recent game
night in the woods is what it's writing
grabbed me with in like two minutes yeah
it doesn't have to be an RPG like I
think you can compare games just on what
they do in general and how good they are
at be yeah a captivating experience that
gets you excited to be in that world to
play a part in it
I was just thrust into this Pathfinder
position suddenly I'm in charge of
everything I like just right off the bat
with like an event that's just really
ham fisted and then like the game is
sort of ushering me around and I don't
feel like I've earned my position I
don't feel like the things I'm doing are
building up to anything really I mean
look at Witcher 3 that's a massive game
it's also an RPG but I was I mean you it
takes a while to really get momentum in
that game right but it's not it's still
right away like you get a really good
sense of the world I think they're
making good use and making me feel like
I'm part of it I get a sensitive Geralt
I get a sense of the people around him
like yennefer or what's his master's
name
doesn't matter Thank You mr. 400 hours
and I came or not more than that
Mountain double for playthrough yeah
$800 sorry how about that all the time
but uh yeah I don't know I again I said
the other day that seems a resume of a I
could have played an entire play sort of
night in the woods at a time the time it
took me to get into Mass Effect yes I
want to touch on that in the woods a
little bit I read an article yesterday I
think it was on Waypoint forgive me for
not knowing who wrote it but it was
about a awkward dialog that's natural
and how night in the woods really
masters that and how when we're speaking
we very rarely speak perfectly the way
we want to right you don't really reform
a sentence and rewrite a sentence and
what night in the woods does really well
is the dialogue is naturally very
awkward like maze just kind of like I
don't know man lit and it feels like how
you would talk to somebody versus the
writing in Mass Effect is awkward in a
natural way if that makes sense like
there's a scene where you're flirting
and she's just like I figure too and I
like having you around and I'm like no
no one says that
and so the the writing and night night
in the woods is what I just want to
highlight that difference like it's not
awkwardness of the problem it's it's the
is it something that a person would
actually say and that goes the opposite
way if you have somebody who's perfectly
articulating themselves all the time is
always eloquent that's also very
unnatural and so you have to find a good
balance when you're writing dialogue was
very hard for a lot of writers because
you're used to crafting beautiful
sentences you're used to retooling a
sentence I think that's definitely
harder to sell on a triple a game though
to make like things like Mass Effect the
original Mass Effect series like had a
lot of tight dialogue but I think it
also left room for that kind of awkward
kind of like I yeah I was actually
looking at the script for rebooted and
you bring up like that scene where
Tolley tally is drunk yeah and I think
like
yeah like a night in the woods is a
different case in a sense because I feel
like you can do something like that you
can make rock or roll mass effect you
have a tight narrative that you're
trying to tell and you need to have like
the characters need to say what they
need to say yeah but I do agree that
like massive that's like the Andromeda
just like can not get like it just takes
itself way too seriously
mm-hmm and filtered too many times
exactly yeah yeah but I guess the
overriding question do you think that
was DLC or I mean obviously there will
be patches that will fix a lot of the
technical bugs but with DLC with
expansions and whatnot do you think
they'll improve the like the core things
we have wrong like maybe they did with
destiny no I don't think so either I I
think that I hope they do make it six
I'm the trying to be positive I own
physics stuff like that like sure that's
possible they're not going to go in and
redo animations
unless someone forgot to check a box
like oh right their eyebrows are
supposed to move whatever put that back
in the game I think that like yeah
animations I don't think they're going
to fix that
I think bugs they'll fix that I think
DLC has the potential to redeem some of
the writing I know one thing about
Dragon Age Inquisition I didn't play all
of it but I do know that the DLC was
some of the best in Inquisition one of
the best parts of Inquisition sorry I'm
just adding a DLC in which Bioware goes
back to when Ryder taking her SATs and
he find out she scored like a 20 or like
oh that amount of personality makes
sense I get it that's why she he or she
is dumb okay
but but I I do think that they can every
for fans who like stuck with Andromeda
like me who even though I'm not in love
with it I'm sticking with it I think
they can redeem it through some really
tight well written DLC uh whether
that'll happen I don't know I hope it
does but as a whole like I don't think
they're going to do anything to bring
someone like Peter Beck or Mike who is a
fan of the other games yeah I mean I I
was telling Pete this is part of a wider
thing and I've been really good lately
about you know like unless I was
reviewing things back last year I don't
review anything anymore and obviously
it's different if you have to review a
game but now that I'm kind of looking
like doing different things I'm better
about not forcing my
self through a game I really don't like
which I realized that you know I am
lucky enough to have access to a lot of
games from a job so I have a lot of
options but I'm also like I feel like I
need to beat Andromeda but I'm really
trying to get myself not to because I
don't I don't see the point I don't
think it's pulling me through and those
things worth it
yeah I don't know like if it's gonna
take you 60 hours and like a lot of that
isn't good like yeah I don't think it's
worth it but you know like at least I
would wait until they patch at least a
little bit of what's wrong with it
but I don't think it's going to fix it
you know intrinsically like you know
like destiny like Callie mentioned
destiny pain King's really good example
I think that actually and that that's
different because destiny is they said
from the beginning Bungie saying Desi's
is almost like a platformer in itself
rather than a singular discrete game max
like itself is a very linear like you
were saying narrative like game and then
sequel trilogy it's not only something
that's constantly evolving the way to
ask me is or like just any multiplayer
game nowadays but I do think that
destiny did a really good job of
addressing major problems and also just
like smaller things that people were
just really bothered by and then that
came through they got a new voice actor
and they rewrote some of his dialogue
and it was awesome
but yeah I don't see stuff like that
happening for Andromeda because I think
the problems are deeper than just what
destiny had yeah I mean I think like I
said this before but I'd be able to
overlook almost every issue if I like if
the writing and dialogue casters are
good definitely there are the authors of
one game yeah the clarify like now it's
like jean-luc psyche like Jake's like
kind of lukewarm Annika you know Scott
still had a good time in the end I think
and you know like it's just a matter of
preferences at this point so read the
reviews decide for what you will I don't
like the game doesn't mean you don't
have to Pete doesn't really like it
doesn't mean you have to Kelly's going
to play more or no I'm yeah I'm gonna
play more I'm pretty I'm pretty on the
fence right now cool alright so that was
our med second trauma to talk about what
you know like whether it can be fixed in
the future based on like the other
Triple A games with rough launches that
we mentioned so let us know what you
think do you like Bioware sorry do you
like Mass Effect Andromeda do you like
what Bioware Montreal has done with this
because I know there are a lot of people
out there that enjoying this game for
and also you know to let us know what
you think they could do in the future
feasibly to fix this I do have one
question I wanna get on really quick
Scott Rabideau on Twitter I believe
thank you for sending a question says is
a new Mass Effect trilogy pretty much
guaranteed at this point like haven't
they said this is going to be kernels
half-sari haven't they said Andromeda
could be a standalone experience yeah so
it sounds like they said it could be a
standalone experience but Scott who's
finished it said there's definitely room
any other that's what it would be anyway
is that yeah so I I mean I don't think
we're gonna get like a trilogy in terms
of like Mass Effect one two and three
where decisions or whatever carry over
but everything will see another Mass
Effect it might be another four or five
years though yeah yeah I mean like
didn't Scott rhabdo saying based on the
performance of Andromeda I think it's
too early to tell I mean I'm sure it
it's going to sell selling again is
going to sell yeah you know that I don't
think that's the issue I think it's the
perception of what they've done and that
how they correct that yeah
Scott Rabideau thank you so much for
your Twitter question I keep I keep
shadows in and everybody thank you so
much for being active in the chat we
appreciate it we like having you here we
are going to wrap up our show but like I
said if you're watching us on YouTube or
GameSpot let us know in the comments
what you think about next second drama
you can go read Scott let's review you
gave it a 6 out of 10 that is up on
GameSpot right now on Sunday at 3 p.m.
Jake and I with the 3rd episode of our
show reboot going up it's I'll get more
in depth with my opinion more
specifically or I guess broadly about
science fiction in video games and just
movies in general and whatnot and also
why I don't think engine Amida kind of
does science fiction well that's not
necessarily Jake's opinion too it's
mainly mine but well yeah you can go
watch that but yeah like I said let us
know you think about the game in the
comments
[Music]